MARCELO CAMELO: Welcome again.
My name is Marcelo.
I'm the tech lead for
the Places API.
I work as part of the Maps
API team in Sydney.
And we're going to be talking
today about writing location
based apps using Google APIs.
So this is the feedback
page for the session.
And also, if you're tweeting
about how awesome your next
location-based app is going to
be, this is the hashtag you'll
want to use.
So yeah, most of the Maps API
team is based in Sydney.
We've created part of that.
And I've got a few stickers
here with a cool Maps API
marker and the Aussie flag, so
you guys can take it after
this session.
So this is the agenda
for today.
And I'm going to give you a
quick intro about what the
Places API is about.
Then I'm going to go over each
of the main features of the
API, alternating between live
demos and cold samples.
It's going to be a bit dry
because I really want to show
you how you use the API.
So I'm going to be using
shell commands.
Be prepared.
And then I'm going to hand it
over to Yoni, from SCVNGR, and
he's going to be telling us
about his experience using the
API from an engineering
perspective.
So instead of telling you what
an API is, I'm going to show
you a quick demo.
So one really cool feature
of the Places API
is the suggest feature.
So I can start typing here say,
the Moscone Center, so it
shows up pretty quickly one
of our first suggestions.
Or I could try say, going a bit
further, Australia-- you
see that it's actually
ranked lower.
That's because I'm looking at
San Francisco, so it's biasing
results within the viewport.
So if I choose Australia,
so there I am.
Now I can go Sydney, right at
the top, Pyrmont [TYPING]
Google Sydney.
So that's where our office is.
So you see, really quick I went
from zooming right in
from the Moscone Center into
the Google office halfway
around the world.
And here I'll do
a Place search.
So returning a couple
of results.
Some of them are what we call
Geocodes: things like suburbs,
localities, cities, and
also local listings.
So Google Sydney is here, I
click on the listing, and I
show some details about
the listing.
So you see over there,
Signorelli Gastronomia, so on
and so forth.
So that's the idea
behind the API.
So it'll give you an easy access
to places in general,
business listings, or a Geocode,
a suburb, a point of
interest in general.
So how do you do this?
There are two main ways to
access the API: one is via the
JS API, and the other one
is via the web service.
Just a quick show
of hands here.
How many of you use
the Maps API?
the Maps API v3?
How many of you have ever
used a library?
All right, maybe 15, 20%.
So for those that don't know,
a library on Maps API v3
allows us to add known core
functionality to the API
without adding bulk
to the binary.
So Places is one more
of those libraries.
So when you specify in the
bootstrap request, an extra
module will be downloaded
with the API.
And all Places API symbols will
be available inside the
Google Maps Places name space.
You also have to set a sensor
flag to either true or false,
depending on where you're
getting your
location signal from.
So the other way to use the API
is via the web service.
So how many of you were thinking
of writing a native
app, running maybe on a--
OK.
So if you want to write a native
app, you probably will
be using the HTTPS service, and
that offers both JSON and
XML endpoints.
You have to sign up for a key
in the developer's console.
It's really easy.
It gives you an API key.
You set the API key for every
request, as I'm doing here in
the example.
And you also set the sensor
flag again, either true or
false, depending where the
location is coming from.
So here I'll show you just what
happens if you try to
send the request
without a key.
The same request now, with the
key set, gets this back.
So, if you look at my request, I
specify the location and the
radius, right?
So I'm doing a 200-meter search
around a specific location.
And what I get back is response
status and a list of
Places in the array
called results.
So it's very straightforward,
actually.
So Place Search, so this
is another demo.
So whenever I drag the map,
it reissues a search.
If I zoom in, it
reissues again.
So you see, it's always
returning 20 results plus
maybe two or three Geocodes.
The results are ranked based on
a Google-specific ranking.
But we're going to see later in
the session that when you
do check-ins, you can
actually have an
impact on that ranking.
So how do you do that search?
So since most of you look more
interested in using it from
the JavaScript perspective,
this is how you do it.
So you declare a request object,
providing a location
and a radius, the location
is the LatLng.
You associate a PlacesService
object.
And you provide either a map
or a div of your own.
And the reason we need that is
because we need to display all
the attributes, the copyrights,
from the list that
we're going to return.
So if you provide a map, the
copyright will appear together
with the attributes
of the map.
Then you call a search on the
Places object, providing the
request, and then a
callback function.
And the callback function will
be called when the results
come back from the Places API.
And it's going to contain an
array of Places in the results
array and also the
response status.
So here I'm ignoring the
You shouldn't when you're
actually try to use this.
But what I'm doing is I'm going
through all the entries
in the array and adding
a marker.
And then you can see, when I
create the marker, I use the
geometry, the location
properties on the Place to set
a position.
I use the name as the
title of the marker.
I use the icon as the custom
image for the marker.
So, really easy.
So if you're using the web
service interface, you're
going to call the Maps API
search, either JSON or XML
endpoints depending on what
you're more comfortable
dealing with, that's a location
of ranges and I
didn't put it there, but also
the key and the sensor flag.
So we've seen what the
results look like.
So it's going to be
a list of places.
And these are the attributes
that come back
on the search result.
So you get name, you got
vicinity, which is a way to
disambiguate two results
if they're the same.
So if you have two Starbucks
within your search radius, you
can provide that to your user so
he can tell to tell the two
Starbucks apart.
A list of types, which are the
categories that are assigned
to that listing, and the
geometry and an icon, so you
can use the icon to display
your results.
So this is a thin slice of the
types that we support.
Just wanted to give
you an idea of how
the API treats types.
So it's actually a hierarchy
of types.
And usually a place is assigned
to one of those leaf
nodes, sometimes
more than one.
It could be, say, a
cafe, a bar and a
restaurant at the same time.
When you get the results
back, you don't get
just the leaf node.
You get the leaf node and all
the parents node of that leaf.
So if it's a bar, you're
going to get bar, food,
establishment, right?
And if it's a neighborhood,
you're going to get
neighborhood, political.
And the icon is also attached to
each of those types, so if
you have a specific icon for
the leaf node, that's what
you're going to return,
Otherwise you're going to
return to the first icon
that shows up the tree.
So in this example, if I'm
returning shoe store because I
don't have a specific icon for
shoe store, I'll just return
you the icon for store.
So, as I said, this is really
a tiny slice of the classes
that we support.
And if you look, the
documentation will list more
than 100 different types.
And you can use those
types in two places.
You can use them if you're
filtering search.
We're going to see that later
how you do filtering by type.
And you can also use it when
you're adding your own places.
There's actually a difference
here at the bottom of the
list. There are some types
that you can't add.
So currently it would not allow
you to add a country or
a locality.
So most of the Geocodes we
don't allow you to add.
So we're looking more at
adding local listings.
So filtering by type, this is
how you do it if you're using
JavaScript.
So, when declaring the request,
in addition to the
location, the radius, you
add a type array.
And in this type array you can
include all the types that
you're interested in getting
back from the Places API.
So in this demo here,
what I have is a
search without any filtering.
And then, when I click on
Museum, I'm actually adding
museum to the list of
types that I want.
Restaurants--
I'm getting museums and
restaurants, lodging, and I
can use any combination
of those.
So that's different from listing
on the client side,
because when I remove a type,
I'm actually allowing some
room for me to fetch
more places.
So, say that I'm doing a search
on a high-density area,
or maybe a bigger radius, when
you have more than actually 20
local listings, a lot of places
will be dropped from
the results.
But if you're interested just in
bars, then you're going to
get much more bars back.
And it's similar if you're
using the web service.
So you provide the types on the
type parameter, and you
use a type separator
between the types.
I'm just going to show you, if
I do a search, that's what I
get back if I search
in New York.
So what I have here, this is a
bit of bash magic because I'm
running a graph and just getting
the types of names of
each of the places that I get
back from the Places API.
So you see, I get neighborhoods,
stores,
university, lodging,
establishment, restaurants.
If I do the same search, but
now you can see that I'm
asking just for restaurants
back, I get the same number of
results, but now all that
I get is restaurants.
And if I do the same search but
now instead of restaurants
I use food--
remember the hierarchy
that we had?
So food is a common parent
between restaurants and bars.
So now you see that, in addition
to restaurants, I got
a grocery shop.
That's because it's also
a food establishment.
So maybe I can skip this
because most of you are
thinking of using the JS API,
but the idea is that if you're
working on a native client, you
probably won't be sending
a request directly from the
client to the Places API.
You'd be proxied via
your server.
Actually, even if you're
using the JS API--
no, maybe not.
But the idea is that your client
will send a request to
the server, the server will
process the request, probably
authenticate the user, and then
translate that request
into a Places API request,
send it to the API.
When you get the response back
from the API, it's going to
augment the results, adding in
some content, and then send it
back to your client.
So the other reason that you do
this is that you don't want
your API key to be installed
on the client,
for security reasons.
So that would only exist
in your server.
Place Details: So if you
remember when I told you what
are the attributes that come
back with a search result,
that's not all the data that
we know about a place.
So you can use the Place
Details request
to fetch more data.
And we actually plan to be
adding more stuff with time to
the Place results.
And we imagine that the results
are going to get
longer and longer and longer, so
it's not really a good idea
to be stuffing all that data
into the search result.
So, the demo again, I click
on the listing.
I'm sending a request to the
API and getting the Place
Details back.
So how do I do this?
I need some form of ID
to request a Place
back from the API.
But when we think of
IDs, we have two
expectations from IDs.
The first expectation is that
you can easily recall with an
ID an entry on a table, an
entry on a database.
Let's call that a recall.
The other purpose you would
expect from an ID is the
ability to tell these two
entries are related, are the
same without having to actually
compare each of the
rules, each of the columns
in the row.
We call that identity.
The thing is, our index of
places is not really a
conventional database.
It's not just places
in a table.
Google is constantly improving
its knowledge of the world.
And because of that,
there's a lot of
instability at the margins.
So we discover new places, new
places actually come into
existence, places may
shut down, or may
fall off our indexes.
There's a lot of overclustering
and
underclustering.
That means that there can be two
different places that show
up in our index as
a single one--
that's overclustering.
Or there can also be a single
place that shows up that's two
individual entries on
the index-- that's
underclustering.
So they cause a lot of ID
fluctuation at the margins.
And although it's not very
likely to impact the place
that we really care about, that
people engage with, we
had to design our API in a way
that it could deal with that
kind of instability.
So what we did is we actually
split the two concepts into
two separate entities
for each place.
One we call reference.
That's where we call from.
And the other one we call ID.
That's what you use when you
want to infer identity.
So use references whenever
you're referencing a
place on the API.
It's optimized for recall.
But It's very likely that it's
going to still be returning
the same place a
year from now.
But you cannot use it
as a key, and I'll
show you why here.
So with a bit of bash magic
here, this thing requests
twice for a Subway.
And you see that on each
request, it returned me a
different reference.
So if I was to use that
reference to tell if that
place is the same, you would
conclude that no, it's not.
On the other hand,
we have IDs.
IDs are used to infer
identities, so to tell if two
places are the same.
It's optimized for stability,
but it cannot be used as a
handle, cannot be used as a
reference anywhere in API.
There's no entrypoint on the API
that you can pass an ID to
get a Place back.
And if I go back and I run this
same example for IDs,
you'll see that IDs come first,
between the two requests.
You're going to see references
and IDs everywhere in the API.
Whenever you get a Place result
back, you're going to
also get a reference
and an ID.
When you add a Place, you get
a reference and an ID.
Suggest gives you back
references and IDs.
And you can think of them
as the Places API ID.
So how do you issue a Place
Request using the JS API?
Again, use the PlacesService
object, and you call the
getDetails method on it.
That's in the request.
In this case, all the
request has is a reference.
And I'm using the Reference
Property on the Place.
The Callback function takes a
Place in the response status.
And what I'm doing, the demo
was just using the Place to
populate the attributes
on the div.
If you use the web service,
similar fashion.
The endpoint is Maps API Place
Details, either JSON or XML,
and the only parameter
is reference.
Just XML output, for a change,
it is exactly the same
structure as the JSON output,
it just uses the XML syntax.
So as I said, the PlaceResult,
when it comes back from Place
Details, has more meat.
So, for instance, you get a
phone number, you get a
rating, you get a
Place page URL.
You can go to the Reference doc
to get a full reference.
So now we're going
to the real-time
capabilities of the API.
So they deal with the real-time
capabilities to
allow you to somewhat customize
the results that you
get back from the API.
All real-time functions are
restricted to your app.
So whenever you do a check-in,
whenever you add a Place or
you delete a Place, you are
only really affecting the
results that your
app gets back.
So the reason for that is what
is relevant to my application
may not be relevant
your application.
And also, we want to protect
you from spammy apps.
So the first feature
is check-in.
So what the check-in is, is
an anonymous relevance
signal to the API.
Because the API is not end-user
authenticated, we
have no notion of what user is
actually sending the check-in
to us, and we don't
really care.
The semantics, we don't have
explicit semantics through the
check-in, so it's up to your app
to decide what that means.
If you're writing a check-in
app, it's maybe your user
telling your application,
hey, I'm here.
Or if you have more of a
recommendation kind of app,
it's probably your user telling
your application, hey,
I found what I'm looking for.
So it affects the ranking
in real time.
Of course, we have only the
first implementation of
real-time ranking.
And as we get more data from
actual usage, we plan to
improve on that.
And we have a lot of ideas.
So the idea is eventually it
should be able to tell a
coffee shop from a night
club, if they're next
door to each other.
During the day, you're going to
probably be checking into
the coffee shop, and during
the night, you're probably
checking into the night club.
So the check-in is actually not
available for the JS API
because the JS API
doesn't have a
notion off an app, right?
So if you want to use check-in,
you're going to have
to use the web service.
And also, it's worth mentioning
that if you're not
using the web service, the
check-in won't affect the
results you get back from
using the JS API.
So because you're actually
writing to your database,
you're required to
use a POST method
instead of a GET method.
And what you're providing the
POST, in the body of the
request, is just the reference
of the place you want to
check-in to.
So this is a check-in request,
and this is all
you get back always.
So all I'm providing here is
the reference of a Place.
The XML endpoint works the same
way, and you also have to
use XML syntax on the
body of the request.
So the second real-time feature
that we have is the
ability to add a Place.
So they used to allow users
and admins to add missing
Places on the fly.
It really depends on your policy
of your app, if you're
going to give that functionality
directly to your
users, or if you're going to
take it on yourself to be
adding the missing Places as
maybe users report, or your
customers claim their business
into your app.
It shows up in the results
immediately, and the users can
engage with it straight away.
So that means that if a user is
trying to check into a bar,
it doesn't show up in the
application, he adds it into
your database.
His friend, right next to him,
can do a search right away,
and it will return his search
results, and he'll be
able to check in.
Again, it's only available
via the web service.
The endpoint is the Maps
API Place Add.
And you provide all the
data about a place
in the request body.
We accept name, location,
accuracy of the location, and
a single type, actually,
for the Place.
And all those are required.
So, just to show you here,
I'll add a taco place.
So see that I get back the
response status, a
reference, and an ID.
[TYPING]
So I added the two Places, so
I got a different reference
and a different ID.
And now I'll do a search.
So because I've added the LatLng
1, 1, there's nothing
else, apart from those Places
I've just added, but you see
they come back straight away.
Let me just add one more.
[TYPING]
There it is.
The same way that you can add
a Place, you can also delete
it from your database.
So the idea is that, if you
allow your users to add a
Place, they may add spam, or
they may add stuff that isn't
really relevant to your app,
or use abusive words.
So you have the ability
to remove
them from your database.
Again, all you need is a
reference, and what I'll do
here, I'll copy the reference
for the pizza place.
And adhere to the delete
request. It's deleted.
I'll search, it no
longer shows up.
If I tried to do it again, it
doesn't find a Place, as you
would expect.
So last but not least,
we have autocomplete.
So, seeing them all again--
so I'll just call your attention
here to the fact
that it highlights the match
between the user input and the
suggestion.
[TYPING]
Also, the fact that it biases
the results, so I have to type
a bit more to get
back to Brazil.
But if I try it from here, from
the B, it is my first
suggestion.
And how do you use this?
It's actually really easy.
On the JS, you declare
text input field.
You then, on JavaScript, get a
handle to that element, and
that's your element in the
construction to the
autocomplete object.
And you're done.
Actually, not quite, but you
already start getting all
suggestions, right?
And then, when the user selects
a Place, an event
called PlaceChanged
will be triggered.
And you can listen to that
event, and maybe update them
at viewport or do whatever you
want with the Place data.
So when you call control
getPlace, when you get back
the Place results, just in the
same way as you got when you
issued up a getDetails request.
So it has all the
information like the name,
full address, a strict
address, icon, so
on and so forth.
So what I'm doing here with the
Place is I'm updating the
map viewport.
So I call this map.fitBounds.
That's in the Place viewport.
But some places do not have a
viewport, so what I do is I
use the location.
And I used the fixed
zoom level.
So the bounds of the
autocomplete is what the
bounds use to bias
the suggestions.
And here I'm listening to the
map's bounds_changed event to
call control the set bounds.
So it couldn't be any
easier than this.
If you're writing a native app
and you also want to deploy
autocomplete into it, there is
also an HTTP web service.
So maps/api/place/autocomplete
endpoint and you'll set the
two arguments: one is
the partial user
input, and the bounds.
[TYPING]
So I have one more demo here.
And it's the Suggest
autocomplete.
Come on!
So you've seen me using curl
in the line, so that's a
really useful way to experiment
with APIs if you
somehow pull the Places API key,
you can just go in any
shell and start playing
with it using curl.
And you can also use, if it's
just a GET method, like for
search, or detail request, or
autosuggest, autocomplete, you
can just use a browser.
So if you look at what an
autocomplete response looks
like, it has description, which
is what we're showing
for the user, it has a list of
types, a reference, an ID, and
then it has a list of terms
which break down the
description.
And then there's also a list
of matched substrings.
So the matched substrings are
what we use to highlight where
the user input matches the
autocomplete suggestion.
And that's not as trivial as it
sounds because sometimes,
if you try doing just a search,
it won't match.
For instance, if you search
for Sao Paolo, you've got
graphic accents on the name of
the city, so you don't need to
type the graphic accent, and but
the suggestion does come
back with an accent.
So that's what I
had for today.
The takeaway we want you guys
to take from here is the
Places API.
It's a service that provides
you advanced local search
services, gives developers
access to Google's super
comprehensive and massive
database of places.
You can access it via the web
service interface or a
JavaScript API.
It's still in Labs, which means
that we're constantly
working to improve it and make
it more useful and usable.
So we need your feedback.
Sign up, try it out, tell
us what you think.
And now, Yoni is going
to tell you about his
experience using the API.
[APPLAUSE]
YONI SAMLAN: Thanks, Marcelo.
My name is Yoni.
I'm the lead Android developer
at SCVNGR, and I'm just going
to talk to you really quickly
about our experiences
integrating the Places
API into SCVNGR.
First off, quick intro:
what's SCVNGR?
SCVNGR is a game that you play
from your Android device, or
iPhone, if you really insist.
It's about going places, doing
challenges, and earning points,
badges, and even
real-world rewards
for playing.
We were one of the larger early
partners to integrate
with the Places API.
When we first started
last year, we had
over 500,000 users.
Now we're almost at 1.5 million,
and growing quickly.
So we were outgrowing our
existing solution, which was
based on GeoAPI, which is now
part of the Twitter API, and
sort of killed off quietly as
part of that, at least for
public usage.
So we needed a solution that
would scale up with us, and we
also have a lot of businesses
that rely on us to engage with
their customers.
A recent Buffalo Wild Wings
campaign we ran earlier this
year was at 780 locations with
180,000 players completing
over 1.2 million challenges.
So we needed a solution that
could scale up to that sort of
size and have the accuracy to
work with a good list of
places to go forward with.
So we turned to Google and
the Places API for that.
So what's it really like,
getting started?
The answer is today, actually
really easy.
As Marcelo showed you, really
all you need is curl and an
API key and you can get going.
Almost all the data you need
to get started building a
location-based app you can get
from just one or two of those
API endpoints.
So that's really great,
especially if you're getting
started today.
It'll be really easy for you.
There are a few little
gotchas--
things that you might run
across, patricularly as you
get ready to actually ship your
app into the real world.
The ID versus references
difference that Marcelo
covered is one of
those things.
So be aware of that.
And also, there is an API
request limit, it's 1,000 by
default, per day.
So before you launch your hot,
stealth-mode startup out into
the world, make sure you
authenticate yourself to get
bumped up to 100,000 a day,
which is very easy to do, it
doesn't cost any money, and will
definitely save you some
headaches that you would have
if you forgot to do that.
And also attributions,
particularly the Places
database has really good data
for especially non-US
locations, where a lot of other
services fall flat, but
they do have a bit of data
that comes back called
attributions that you have to
show your users, which is
where that data is
sourced from.
That also applies to mobile
clients, so don't be stuck
scrambling to update your iPhone
and Android clients
last minute before
launch with that.
Be aware of that from
the outset.
But those are really
little things.
The bottom line is what happens
when you move to the
Places API?
For us, it was a
win all around.
Uncached place listing
requests--
what are the places near me--
for us, sped up about
three times.
Mostly because we were able to
replace a lot of areas where
we had to make multiple API
calls to remote services with
just one call to the Places
API, which was great.
The data's a lot
more complete.
We found that the ratio of users
adding places versus
visits went down by about 40%,
meaning that users were just
finding the places they were
looking for more often without
having to go through the kind
of painful manual process of
typing in a place from scratch,
which is really good,
especially for mobile
applications.
And finally, and probably
hardest to quantify, the data
is just cleaner.
We have a lot less of a problem
with junk data,
duplicate places, old places
that aren't around anymore.
And we don't have to go through
a process we used to
have to go through to remove
spam places-- especially spam
locksmiths, for some reason--
that were in a lot of
our other data sets.
So that was great.
And I'll leave you with just a
few of the features that are
new to the API versus what was
there last year, that I'm most
excited about as a developer.
First of all, that check-ins
matter now.
When you post a check-in back to
the Places API, that's used
for adjusting the rankings of
those Places short term.
So if we're running a promotion,
for example, with
Toscanini's, an ice cream shop
in Cambridge, Toscanini's will
rise up in the rankings while
that promotion or that event
is going on, with no manual
intervention necessary on our
part just because our users
are checking in there.
And then once they're done,
once that event is over,
Toscanini's will fall back to
its normal ranking, although
probably not quite that, because
it'll inherently be
more popular because
of our event there.
And the second thing I'm
pretty excited about is
instant Place adds.
With most other Place APIs, and
the old way it worked on
the Google Places API, if your
users reported a new place
that was missing from the
database, you'd have to either
tell that user that they
couldn't do anything there
until it's approved, or you'd
have to keep a local copy of
that place and merge it with the
data coming back from the
remote API, and then once it
got approved on the remote
end, you'd have to go through
some sort of de-duplication
process and move all
the activity
over to the new place.
You don't have to
do that anymore.
The results come back your app
now instantly, and eventually
they'll get approved for
everybody else using the APIs,
which is really nice and
means a lot less
bookkeeping for you.
And the bottom line is, by
moving to the Places API,
we've improved the experience
for our end users, for our
business clients, and it's made
life easier for us as
developers.
And at the end of the day, it
means everybody can spend less
time tweaking lists
of locations
and more time playing.
And really, that's what
it's all about.
And on that note, I'll pass
things back to Marcelo, and
we'll open the floor
up to Q&A.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: I have a question
about the ratings and reviews.
I see when I go to the
maps.google.com Places
detailed result, is there any
plans to integrate that into
the service, or more
detailed aggregate
reviews from other places?
MARCELO CAMELO: Yes there is.
That's a roadmap, definitely.
AUDIENCE: Is a sign-up
required for
the JavaScript API?
And when you do an add through
the web service API, is that
added site essentially stored
underneath your key?
MARCELO CAMELO: So there's no
sign-up for the JS API.
And I don't know if I understood
your question, but
there's no add from
the JS API.
AUDIENCE: Right, but when you
use the web service and you
add something--
I've added it, is it cluttering
up his results?
MARCELO CAMELO: No.
AUDIENCE: So it's stored
underneath my key.
MARCELO CAMELO: Exactly.
AUDIENCE: So I think you kind
of addressed this, but the
reference that comes back is
different every time you call
the API, even with the
same client ID.
And you mentioned that there are
times when there might be
duplicates, right?
Like, it's been underclustered.
What happens if those two
entities get merged?
MARCELO CAMELO: So both
references will now fetch the
merged place.
AUDIENCE: I was trying out the
autocomplete feature and I
noticed that there was geocoding
that's put into it
so you can actually look up
addresses as well as just
Place names.
One thing I was having some
trouble with, though, is that
I have a service which has food
trucks as a major user of
it, and they always want
to use intersections.
And I didn't see that there
was any support for
intersections at current.
Are there plans for that?
MARCELO CAMELO: No.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
MARCELO CAMELO: But it's a
really interesting idea.
How would you look for
an intersection?
Maybe Thor knows.
AUDIENCE: Because right now,
when I use the Geocode, the
Geocoder has a great feature
where you just type in Fifth
and Mission, and it'll turn to
Mission Avenue and Fifth
Street, San Francisco,
California
as one of the options.
But it doesn't seem to be
that way in Places.
THOR MITCHELL: I think one of
the things I kind of expect
and accept that we're going to
have to say a lot over the
next year is it's important
to understand that the
autocomplete service
is not a Geocoder.
It's not designed or intended
to be used as a Geocoder.
It is designed to be used to
complete queries and to find
individual places
by their name.
Now, in the case of an
address object, then
the name is the address.
So you could enter the name of
a street and you could enter
the name of a city, and even
if those two things are not
next to each other in the
address, we would match it for
autocomplete.
That would work.
But the Geocoder service, the
official one, can do other,
more smart things, where its
whole purpose in life is to
try and give you back a LatLng
for the query you've given us.
So we'll take that query and it
will try and split it, and
decompose it, and do analysis on
it to try and infer as much
meaning as possible from that
query in order to give you
back a LatLng.
And you'll notice that the
autocomplete service does not
give you back a LatLng
by design.
It gives you back a reference,
which you can use to get a
LatLng if you really want one.
But we actually don't want to
encourage its use as an
alternate Geocoder.
In fact, if there are reasons
why you're finding you're
getting more success in
searching the places in
autocomplete than you do in the
Geocoder, then we consider
that to be a bug in the
Geocoder, and we'd like to
know about it.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
By the way, is there any
way to supplement the
autocomplete?
THOR MITCHELL: What, with
your own list of--
AUDIENCE: With some other API.
MARCELO CAMELO: So you could,
then, if you're using the web
service, right?
Because you're getting
the result back.
But we do have plans to allow
you to extend how both how the
controls that I showed you work
and also to provide you a
service inside the JS API.
So you could autocomplete with
a request and then get back a
list of results instead of
injecting that into a div.
THOR MITCHELL: Also, I'll just
take this opportunity to say
that we prioritized the control
we have at the moment
or at least the feature we have
at the moment in the JS
API where we actually
implement the
drop-down for you.
We wanted to make it as easy
as possible because we want
every single field on the web
which asks someone for an
address to implement
autocomplete because the world
would be better for it.
AUDIENCE: Hi, my
name is Thomas,
and I've got a question.
Who is actually meant to add or
delete the new locations?
Is that the user of the
application, or who does it?
MARCELO CAMELO: It really
depends on your app.
You could give that power to the
user if you trust them to
do with the right thing.
Or, you know, crowd-sourcing
it, or you could do it like
having admin people
doing it for you.
THOR MITCHELL: I think a
particularly interesting
question on that topic is how
do you handle deletes?
I think many apps still allow
users to add places and they
just assume that that place is
good, and they publish it
immediately.
But for deletes, you could, for
example, say, if five of
my users signal to us that
this place is bad, we'll
delete it just to avoid
someone just going and
deleting everything.
AUDIENCE: So again, this is
probably a stupid question,
but so there are no rate limits
on the JavaScript
version of the API?
THOR MITCHELL: There are rate
limits, although we don't
publish them because we don't
want to encourage people to
push them and because we need
the freedom to change
them or vary them.
So there are rate limits that
apply per map session.
There are no daily limits.
Because that doesn't really
apply to maps that appear
within web pages where you can
have multiple tabs for
different pages open,
and so forth.
AUDIENCE: So a mapping session
is some combination of IP and
source URL and all
these things?
THOR MITCHELL: A map session is
one single load of the Maps
API regardless of how much
activity then follows.
So within that, there are rate
limits that apply, but let's
say they're not documented.
AUDIENCE: Hi, one more question:
is there a way to
get user-specific check-ins so
that I can prioritize the
places that a user themself
has checked in, over just
general, every place
in my app?
MARCELO CAMELO: No, so, as I
said, we don't know who the
user is because the user is not
authenticated with us, and
there's no way for
you to tell us.
So currently no.
THOR MITCHELL: It's something
that we've considered and that
we could implement
in the future.
There are some interesting
questions around privacy that
come into play at that
point when we
have an explicit end-user.
But, in fact, the questions
become a lot more complicated
if we just have a signal as
the user, rather than
actually, for example,
a Google account.
At least with a Google account,
we can provide them
with tools to manage the data
that we've stored and to
delete the data that
we've stored.
But if you're just giving us
some opaque identifier, we
have information stored about
users and we can't provide
them with any way to manage that
data, which isn't good.
AUDIENCE: Is there a limit
on the radius?
For example, if we want
to search within
30 miles in a city--
MARCELO CAMELO: So we're
actually working on this at
the moment, and there
probably will be.
AUDIENCE: But right now
there's nothing.
MARCELO CAMELO: You can
assume that there is.
We're still trying to
nail down a number.
THOR MITCHELL: Yeah, I mean,
bear in mind, you only ever
get 20 results.
So the broader you search,
you're essentially--
because of the way the ranking
algorithm works-- particularly
in the absence of
any check-ins--
we give you the top 20
places in that area.
And so as that area gets bigger
and bigger, you're
going to end up with just
really, really,
really major landmarks.
MARCELO CAMELO: Like Empire
State Building
and Statue of Liberty.
AUDIENCE: Oh, one more thing:
with regards to caching the
information, do you guys have
any terms on that, like what
we cannot do?
THOR MITCHELL: We don't have
terms that are specific to the
Places API.
But the Maps API terms of
service, which the Places API
falls under, have language
around rights to cache that,
that basically say that you
can cache reasonable
quantities, small quantities
of data, for performance
reasons, and the reference and
IDs you're allowed to store
for as long as you like.
And you can always use
those to refresh
cached data as well.
The most important things there
are that you need to
only use the data in conjunction
with the Maps API,
Places API application--
you can't use it outside
of an application.
And if at any point you choose
to stop offering this
application or switch to a
different source of Places
data, then you have
to dispose of the
data that you've cached.
AUDIENCE: So stuff that I add
using my Add key, is that
available to only my
application, or will that be
available to everybody?
MARCELO CAMELO: No, it's only
available to your application,
only to that specifically.
THOR MITCHELL: Until
it's moderated.
So when you add something, it
immediately turns up in your
subsequent set results, but it
does also get passed into
Google's moderation pipeline for
when new Places, the same
one that's used on Google maps
when you report a new place.
If it gets successfully
moderated, then it will go
into Google's main index and
be visible across all of
Google's properties and to other
Places API applications.
If it does not get successfully
moderated, it
will still continue to be
available to your application.
AUDIENCE: And how long does it
take for it to moderate?
THOR MITCHELL: That varies.
It's of the order of weeks.
AUDIENCE: OK.
And I understand I need to use
the Add key when I add stuff
to it, but I can curate
using the
JavaScript without the key?
THOR MITCHELL: You don't need
a Places API key to use the
JavaScript, but the JavaScript
will not return app-specific
places, in other words,
places that have
not yet been moderated.
MARCELO CAMELO: All the
real-time features, you don't
go them when you
use the JS API.
AUDIENCE: OK, so there's no
way to add the key to the
JavaScript API.
THOR MITCHELL: No, the problem
is that because all JavaScript
applications are, by definition,
publicly visible,
I can just hit View Source
and wade through.
Then I could find your
key very easily
and just hammer it.
So we didn't want
to allow that.
AUDIENCE: How you guys doing?
My question's on Place ID
or reference ID facets.
Have you given thought to, for
example, other facets of
spatial locations?
One might be temporal, for
example, the definition of a
spatial location may change
over time, whether or not
you're going to be
storing that--
first part.
The second is, how immutable
are these IDs?
You said earlier, for instance,
two reference IDs
might get merged and point
to one specific location.
So it sounds to me like if
you're issuing an ID or
reference IDs that someone else
then receives, then it's
more or less guaranteed to
always resolve to something
once a query is made
with that ID.
And then also, the
caching question.
I just want to reiterate
on the caching--
you're not the only place
provider, there are other
people who are doing IDs, so
how kosher is doing like a
global placing map between your
services and other services?
THOR MITCHELL: OK, so
I think there were
three questions there.
Let me see if I can
remember them.
Right.
So as far as facets are
concerned, it's
a good point that--
and something I mentioned in
the session yesterday--
places is a very fuzzy
and broad concept.
We as people, we can define
places in all sorts of ways,
and some of them can be
personal: I can say, my house,
I can say, the place
I got married.
Some of them can be relative:
I can say, that coffee shop
opposite the hardware store.
And some of them can be
completely transient, like a
state fair.
Some of them can be in motion,
such as flights, for example,
you know, I'm on QF73
or whatever.
And these are all use cases
which ideally we'd like to be
able to support well
in the long term.
For the time being, we've taken
a position that a single
place is an object with a fixed
location and a fixed name.
So for the time being, we don't
support things like,
say, moving objects.
I think temporal awareness
is very important.
There's no doubt that people
would like to check into
events, for example, as
well as into places.
It's much more interesting to
tell your friends that you're
at the Lady Gaga concert than
that you're at the HP
Pavilion, for example.
So, event support is something
that is absolutely on the
roadmap, not necessarily as a
new type of place but as a
property of an existing place.
That's the more likely model.
OK, second question was--
AUDIENCE: The immutable nature
of your identification scheme.
THOR MITCHELL: So the goal of
the Places API reference is
that a Places API reference,
for any given place, should
continue to always return that
place for as long as that
place continues to exist. So
clearly places of business
close, and what we don't
currently support is the
ability to retrieve information
about a place
after it's no longer
in the index.
We realize that may actually
be important.
You're checking history,
ultimately, you may span years
and years, and you don't want
to lose that context.
So that's something that we're
going to have to consider.
But right now, as long as our
business continues to exists,
we will match it.
And the way we do that is the
whole reason we have a
separate reference is because
the references you will see
are significantly longer, and
although they appear to be
garbage, it's actually
effectively an encrypted
search that gives us a way of
falling back through different
means of matching, in the case
of drift of attributes that we
rely on for that purpose.
AUDIENCE: And the
last was caching
and creating a matching--
THOR MITCHELL: We're definitely
very aware, and
this was one of the great pieces
of feedback that came
out in the developer preview.
It really shows the
value of it.
Because it wasn't something that
we picked up on at first.
Something that's extremely
valuable to these
location-based app developers
is what they call
distribution--
the ability to make people
aware of their app in a
crowded market space of hundreds
of thousands of
iPhone and Android
applications.
Awareness is key.
Now, one of the main ways in
which applications rely on
this kind of awareness
right now is
through social networks.
If I download an app and use
it and then do a check-in,
that check-in gets written to
my Twitter stream or to my
Facebook page.
And in doing so, my friends
see that and may choose to
join the party, as it were.
And so it's important, that in
those cases, you can write
your check-ins across
these services.
So we do actually have language
in the terms of
service that address this.
And the basic rule of thumb is
that if I do a check-in using
an app that's based on the
Places API, I pull back a set
of information about
that place.
What I can do is take, say, the
location of that place,
and then do a search on a
third-party API and attempt to
match those things
developer-side, if you like,
in your infrastructure in
order to find the ID.
That's perfectly fine.
What we ask that you don't do
is submit data that you've
received from our API
to those services.
So that means two things: it
means I get a LatLng from the
user's phone, I do a search on
the Place API, I come back
with a set of places, I present
them with one, they
choose one, great.
I then do a similar LatLng-based
search on some
other API, they give me
back a set of places,
I match them, great.
What you can't do is take the
place name and use it as a
search query over
here, all right?
Similarly, you can't say, oh,
they don't have that place,
I'm going to create it using
the data I got from Google.
AUDIENCE: Fair, fair.
THOR MITCHELL: I think
we're out of time.
MARCELO CAMELO: Out of time.
THOR MITCHELL: I'm happy to chat
more afterwards if that
would be useful.